you're the boss on the mindy project you
are the boss and you got a little into a
little trouble last time you were here
because you went on a bit of i'm going
to call it a rant
against
you about your employees having long
birthday celebrations while they're
supposed to be working and i guess you
took some heat for that yes i i got in
trouble here because i am not someone
who thinks that if you're over the age
of 16 you should make a big deal about
birthday celebrations but i know that's
incredibly unpopular and i live i
learned my lesson and so now i allow
them
partially because everyone was like
you're a dictator go back to north korea
right we want to have mirth at our
workplace right sure and i was like so
now i allow it but my big thing is you
have to sing happy birthday
faster because
as a culture
now they wheel out a cake the entire
crew of 200 people stops everything
we're doing and by the way with 200
people there's a birthday like every day
yes so it's constantly and it's like
what was that i don't know i just heard
a noise was that your hair brushing up
against your microphone possibly kind of
like it was somebody
something accidental
what i don't know i don't think it was
you i thought it was a reaction to my
like terrible behavior no no no no like
one of them no it sounded like somebody
checking on my hair backstage
this isn't like a haunted set right i
want to go back
i don't want to be part of it i felt
safer in the popcorn
wait you can't tell people to
happy birthday has a certain cadence
that is time
you can't pick it up it's a happy song
it's not a dirge it's really not a happy
song so now i'm like i do this
and people don't like that either but
you know i'm trying to become better we
get annoyed about it here because we
have the same thing we have how many
people work here andy seven thousand
okay
we have seven thousand employees here at
konico i don't know i'm like the pharaoh
atop the pyramid i can't
i can't be involved in everything
just make the bricks make the bricks
build my tomb
faster
but yeah like every time i turn a
hallway people are like quick there's a
giant sheet cake a nine-story sheet cake
you know cause stiz radwell's having a
party
one of the winners of the mtv movie
award so now i'm getting into trouble
again because i can already tell that my
work they're like she's so mean this is
the thing my nice sweet assistant is
like
it's one of your writers birthdays what
do you want to get them and i'm like i'm
not getting them anything they have a
job
that's the gift
that i give them
that's what then that's what scrooge
says and he's like
you i implore you bob crutchet you know
that's all you'll get you know as i'm
saying this i feel i should backtrack no
it's too late no you just said that you
told your you told your assistant no
presents i give them the ultimate
present employment no i'm not
do they wear fingerless gloves in your
office yeah yeah and sit on tall stools
and write in books yeah i pay them in
twigs
this is hollywood
listen i can't come on the show and
apologize again for this segment yes you
are i won't do this this is how we
rebook you we get you in trouble
and then you have to come back and
apologize and now you have to come back
and apologize